in this lesson we're going to discuss a
healthcare application of clustering
called phenotyping
phenotypes are medical concepts such as
diseases or conditions
we know many phenotypes of patients
based on existing medical knowledge
such as major diseases but there are
many more phenotypes and their subtypes
out there that we haven't discovered
computational phenotyping is a way to
use data available to us to discover
those novel phenotypes
phenotypes aren't just for disease
diagnosis though
we can also use those phenotypes for
predicting health care cost
readmission risk and supporting genomic
studies
now let's talk about computational
phenotyping
computational phenotyping is about
converting raw electronic health record
through phenotyping algorithms into a
set of meaningful medical concepts
or phenotypes for example a specific
disease can be a phenotype
such as type 2 diabetes and the raw data
in this case consists of many different
sources
such as demographics about patients
diagnosis code
medication information clinical
procedure lab result and clinical notes
there are many reasons why phenotypes
are not represented consistently
or reliably in the raw data first the
data are noisy there are missing data
and raw information in the raw data
and second the main usage of this data
is to support clinical operations
such as billing and it's not designed
directly for supporting research
third there are many overlapping and
redundant information
for example diagnosis information can be
found in the structure field
corresponding to diagnosis code
but the same information can also be
present as in structure information in
the clinical notes
this information is overlapping and
redundant in the raw data
and phenotyping is this process of
deriving research-grade phenotypes from
clinical data
using computer algorithms
here's a phenotyping algorithm for type
2 diabetes
and the goal here is we want to
determine whether patient has type 2
diabetes
based on her electronic health records
for example
we can first check whether the patient
has type 1 diabetes code in her record
if no then we check whether type 2
diabetes diagnosis are present in her
record
if still no then we check medication for
type 2 diabetes
then check abnormal lab result related
to diabetes
if these two steps are confirmed then we
confirm she has type 2 diabetes
there are many different paths that can
lead to the confirmation of type 2
diabetes
and this decision flow is a phenotyping
algorithm
this was developed manually by clinical
experts
there are many different applications
that require phenotyping
for example genomic study which is about
finding relationship between genomic
data and phenotypic data
clinical predictive modeling which is
about building an accurate
robust and interpretable prediction
model about disease onset
and other related targets such as
hospitalization
and pragmatic clinical trials which is
about comparing treatment effectiveness
in the real world clinical environment
using observational data
like electronic health records and
health healthcare quality measurement
which is about measuring efficiency in
quality of care across different
hospitals
all those applications depends on
phenotyping algorithms
you